l'entrée du domaine offre un panorama
exceptionnel sur ce château de la
Renaissance aujourd'hui reconverti en
hôtel 4 étoiles
il faut s'éloigner un peu et s'aventurer
dans le potager pour y découvrir une
collection unique au monde nous ne
parlons pas de tableau ni de sculpture
mais de tomates là c'est une variété qui
s'appelle summersideer alors là faudra
me croire sur parole parce que pour
l'instant on verra que les fruits sont
tout petits mais c'est une variété qui
va faire des fruits de cette taille là
qui mûrissent plutôt tardivement on va
être à partir de mi-août début septembre
pour la maturité c'est des gros fruits
orangés avec une chair très fine et
fondante là c'est une variété qui
s'appelle la Russe donc on voit la Russe
c'est une variété qui est très très
vigoureuse qui va donner elle aussi des
gros fruits très tardivement plutôt en
fin d'été donc faut imaginer des fruits
qui peuvent faire le kilo facilement
c'est une une variété qui est assez
appréciée des jardiniers
depuis 25 ans le château de la
Bourdaisière abrite le Conservatoire
National de la tomate alors là ce que je
fais ça permet en fin de compte de
d'aérer la surface du sol et en même
temps ça fait office de désherbage
puisque je coupe les racines des plantes
et donc elles vont les adventistes là
qui poussent sur le sol en fait vont
sécher sur le sol comme j'aurais coupé
la racine
ces noms ne vous disent sans doute pas
grand chose elles font partie des 700
variétés cultivées ici certains
spécimens sont très rares
ces variétés ciennes sont plus cultivées
ni par les maraîchers ni par les
jardiniers particuliers elle risque de
perdre et donc on aurait une érosion
génétique au fil du temps donc le but
c'est de préserver donc ces variétés
anciennes donc c'est pour ça que chaque
année je fais le travail de refaire les
graines ensuite elles vont être
conservées au réfrigérateur et je les
resserme l'année suivante
des tomates qu'il est possible de
déguster sous ce barnum à quelques
mètres de là où elles ont poussé on se
promène dans les jardins de la
Bourdaisière et on peut venir déjeuner
ici juste après donc les visiteurs
apprécient beaucoup cette formule il y a
un côté vraiment du chant à l'assiette
qui se fait en direct
en gaspacho jus ou salade la tomate sous
toutes ses nuances au milieu des jardins
du château d'ailleurs ce jour-là c'est
de la ratatouille qui viendra égayer les
papilles des clients